llegó aquí con una traqueotomía
[Música]
serpiente te acabamos de ver
responde a tus ojitos
que los primeros 10 contactos
primeros 10 minutos que ya tenemos
un contacto con el animal que tenemos
liberación de neurotransmisores que es
serotonina que son neurotransmisores
que son la sensación de placer y
bienestar para que se sienta bien tiene
ganas de aprender
[Música]
mis grandes avances superando y
cada día que pasa ha avanzado
más y superado, la discapacidad, derecho
porque es autista
[Música]
Estoy guiando al animal a hacer
que cada vez que me doy cuenta el puede
empieza a estresarte ya hablo
para André que tenemos que cambiar
porque en ningún momento queremos
invadió el espacio de bienestar de ese
animal
[Música]